alright let's jump into the news so
their reports coming out of the Trump
administration with regard to Syria and
by reports I mean conflicting reports
conflicting positions on what Donald
Trump's foreign policy actually is is
there a coherent foreign policy coming
out of the Trump administration with
regard to Syria we have conflicting
statements from the president from his
secretary of state and from his
ambassador to the UN nikki Haley
president Trump said on yesterday that
we are not going into Syria which if you
are a non-interventionist or anyone who
has taken a look at the United States
history with interventions that is good
news Rex Tillerson the Secretary of
State however had some different things
some different opinions and he's had
differing differing opinions the entire
time he suggests that a side must go he
suggests that America will do what's
necessary to get rid of a side he's even
going as far as to let Russia know I and
he's actually only trip in Moscow right
now to let Russia know that their allies
ship with Assad is questionable that
Assad is not a good Ally and that Russia
should reconsider their relationship
with Syria all in light of the chemical
attacks and it live on last week for
which Donald Trump launched 59 Tomahawk
missiles and destroyed twenty percent of
the capacity of the air force base from
which the attacks were launched this is
pretty much where we are today the
question still remains is there a
coherent strategy it doesn't look like
there is Pat it looks like it's a
disjointed kind of chaotic approach that
he's had to Syria all along what are
your thoughts well it's certainly a 180
flip but I think given the events that
have unfolded within the past week the
chemical attacks by the Assad government
you can see at least where they're
coming from why they would make that
change but it doesn't make sense Trump
saying that we're not going into Syria
we're already there he's very same thing
with regards to the Russians going into
Ukraine they're already there yeah
they're already there
yeah I mean I mean it would be funny if
it wasn't such a significant story with
far-reaching ramifications there's a lot
of commentary as to how Donald Trump
carried out the missile strikes whether
or not he should or should not have
notified Russia prior to the strike i
would say in the midst of all of the
things that could have gone wrong and
probably did go wrong notifying russia
that we're going to attack this base to
prevent us from killing any Russians and
getting into a conflict with Russia I
think was probably the best thing to
come out of this story am I in my
opinion what do you think you absolutely
had to because if Russian soldiers were
killed in that exactly things could
spark you know if Syria and Iran and
Russia all band together we may have
world war three this exactly so that's
the least of the of the bad things
actually there's a good thing that came
out of this in the midst of a lot of bad
things what surprises me the most is
something that I floated on my show last
week because I could not understand Pat
why Donald Trump would make a complete
180 losing some of his core support from
the alt right whatever you want to call
them because he is now forwarding an
interventionist foreign policy which is
completely opposite 180 from where he
was in the campaign I could not figure
out for the life of me why he would do
this last week we floated up because we
saw the tweets from me bunker Trump that
it could have been the result of ivanka
being troubled by what she saw turns out
that was not just a trial balloon that's
actually what happened according to Eric
trump donald trump's 33 year old son he
was speaking to a british outlet he said
that Ivanka Trump's um Ivanka Trump's
dis being disturbed actually played in
two Donald Trump's decision and so
that's that's kind of disturbing when
you consider that he would make such a
drastic change on foreign policy as a
result and I have a quote here from them
as a result of Ivanka Trump opinion on
the issue this is what Eric trump said
to The Daily Telegraph is
ivanka is a mother of three kids and she
has influence and he said I'm sure she
said listen this is horrible horrible
stuff air Trump went on and said that my
father will act in times like that like
considered we he shifted on a major
foreign policy issue as a result of his
daughter being upset I mean what else
can she get us into right and at first
when we found out that Ivanka Trump
would have a large role in the Trump
administration I at least thought that
even though it would violate anti
nepotism laws had she had a title it may
actually be a good force on him because
she seems to be a little bit younger you
know more pressive and she actually
invited relatively speaking yeah and she
she invited outdoor and to speak to
trump about climate change so I thought
she would be a good force on him it
turns out that's not the case right it's
not the case because if evanka has
enough sway well let's just look at it
from this perspective it's not so much
that I'm concerned that Donald Trump is
influenced by his daughter as much as he
doesn't have a solid enough foreign
policy to whether the influence of his
daughter right if he had a solid
worldview foreign policy worldview that
he actually believed in it would not be
so easily swayed by his daughter or any
advisor he would view the world that way
and stick to his guns nope I intended
because during the campaign he'd take
any position on the table there
sometimes he was a non-interventionist
other times he would go way further than
the politicians we have here and would
say things like we have to take out
their families yeah yeah it was a
completely disjointed foreign policy to
begin with he was not I think some
people interpreting him as a pacifist
he's clearly not a pacifist if he's a
non-interventionist he's a
non-interventionist to the extent that
he will get involved in another nations
issues for any type of humanitarian ISM
humanitarianism any type of thing that's
not beneficial directly to America this
America first paradigm so it's not that
he was a pacifist and anyone who
believed that was sadly mistaken it was
that he was not going to get involved in
another country if it wasn't something
like like it Islam right if Donald Trump
waged war against Islam all the people
all of his alt right supporters who are
mad at him now would still be in love
with him not because they are pacifist
clearly no they're ok with conflict so
long as it's a conflict that they fits
into their ideological worldview and
he's also a populist first and foremost
so if he's speaking in front of a crowd
and he can tell that you know the
American public sick of war by this
point because we've been in the Middle
East you know for 15 consecutive years
yes a well maybe we should take a step
back from this we should put our
resources towards building up our own
country but if there is an attack like
what happened last week then he's going
rah rah rah we got to respond to this
especially as a result of being
influenced by his daughter I mean I'll
leave all commentary about historical
people there's one last thing that we
have to get to on this story and it's
the polling that shows this dramatic
flip from the GOP in terms of support
for the attack from the Washington Post
us ABC Washington Post poll in 213
thirty-seven percent I'm sorry
thirty-eight percent of Democrats
supported the attack or the planned
attack by President Obama in 2017
thirty-seven percent supported
underneath Donald Trump pretty
consistent definitely within the margin
of error Republicans however eighty-six
percent supported underneath Trump 22%
supporter underneath President Obama a
stark contrast completely partisan a
flip I mean it there's no other way to
describe that besides flip-flopping it's
okay if their guy does it but not okay
if the President Obama did it it's
hilarious because I think now it's been
so many years people are starting to go
back to the idea of maybe we should get
involved in the Middle East we have a
short memory on that it seems but if
that was true i think the Democratic
poll numbers would be higher right in
support of Trump right and and it's it's
refreshing to be honest and candid it's
very refreshing to see the Democrats be
consistent on anything but I'll leave
that alone but it's not surprising to
see that the Republicans are all for
something when they're President does it
and all against it it's this is football
sports like paradigm and politics
if my team does it it's okay if the
opposite team does it it's not okay and
this is what we're seeing with regard to
Syria there's a YouTube advertiser
boycott going on which means ads are not
playing on our YouTube channel which
means we're no longer making any money
from these videos please help us fight
back and replace that revenue you can
become a member at david pakman.com
slash membership if you want to discount
use the coupon code I voted 17 we need
your help